[Music]
here's your money briefing for Tuesday
April 4th I'm J.R Whelan for the Wall
Street Journal
online groups like Freecycle and buy
nothing that promote giving away free
unwanted Goods have become popular on
social media and now that ecosystem has
extended to Travelers and no we're not
just talking about hotel shampoo or a
couple of bars of soap Don Gilbertson
writes the wsj's carry-on travel column
and she joins me to discuss how these
groups have created a treasure hunt of
sorts for hotel guests hey Don thank you
very much for being with us thanks for
having me Jr so Dawn free stuff I
thought there was no such thing as a
free lunch you know uh there's a
surprising little corner of the travel
industry where you can pick up some
other people's vacation leftovers I
discovered it in Las Vegas and found
it's much more prevalent than I thought
uh you're not talking about like
leftover food right
oh no I'm not talking about last night's
Chinese delivery to your room I'm
talking about things like bottled water
Foods snacks the things that you know a
lot of times we go on vacation we get
all excited we buy all this stuff for
our room and then we have stuff left
over at the end and this is just a way
to share it with others
so how did this trend start paying it
forward and sharing things with other
Travelers just like with other neighbors
on those buy nothing and Freecycle
groups has been around for a long time
but what's different now is their
Facebook groups devoted to sharing this
information you know for example at the
Disney Vacation Club which is Disney's
timeshare I mean several of those
complexes have their own Facebook group
where you know say families that are
checking out can say hey we have
strollers we have diapers we have water
we have soda here's where we're located
or here's where we're gonna put it and
would you like to come and get it for
free yeah I was going to ask you where
are these things left for people then to
come and get it it really varies by
hotel by destination and Yellowstone
there's a Facebook group for Yellowstone
visitors and you know some people say
hey we're leaving today we're going to
leave this at this place outside the
park or in our hotel in Las Vegas a
really popular place for some reason
maybe just to kind of keep it out of the
way way is ice machine rooms and vending
machines people that have something to
give away for free will post a picture
in these Facebook groups and say hey
come and get it it's here here's where
it's located so how much of this leaving
behind free things is people just not
wanting to be wasteful it's
nice generous and not wasteful the one
of The Travelers I talked to said you
know every time the they go on vacation
they buy so much stuff and they end up
throwing it away or they worry it's
going to get thrown away by the
housekeepers you know because hotels
have different policies on that so it's
just a way to say hey let me do
something good with this are the hotels
and the resorts are they okay with the
free stuff being left behind do they
understand the fact they should not
quickly sweep all this up no it's
interesting I reached out to the two
largest hotel chains in Las Vegas and in
fact one of the people I talked to
wasn't even aware of it so it's not like
there's six cases of bottled water you
know on the casino floor I think it's
hidden enough where it's not a problem
you know some people say they leave it
with the Bellman they'll leave a note
some people just stick it out outside
their door and they'll put a sign up
that says free so you know really
Travelers just have to be on the lookout
for this kind of thing that they're
trying to save a buck sounds like the
sort of thing you might see on
somebody's front yard a sign next to an
appliance or something that says come by
free take it yeah it's like bulk trash
day for travel you know except it's a
little more organized and the things can
be valued valuable I mean one of the
biggest items in Las Vegas in the group
that I talk to is coffee machines people
either have one cent or bring a small
like coffee maker or carrig from home
and then they'll re-gift that to people
when they leave so you know that can
that can save you a lot of Starbucks
money
so Dawn how would somebody find out if
there are free things at the hotel that
they're going to so besides looking
around when you're there and looking for
those little things that say free you
know looking around the front desk the
most important tip that I could give is
to look for Facebook groups that are
focused on your destination you know
you'll see it in there and you'll find
all these groups where people are
sharing things so you know when you're
doing your regular research for your
trip see if this might be an option
here's the thing though you can't count
on it and some groups by the way have a
very very strict rules like you can't
send them your grocery list here's what
I'm looking for you know what I mean and
have somebody like you know deliver it
to your door I mean the onus is on the
traveler here someone else is being nice
to you so don't expect too much this is
quite a camaraderie among Travelers
there are actually nice people left in
the world uh 100 it's good to know isn't
it
all right that's Wall Street Journal
columnist Don Gilbertson with us Dawn
thanks so much for being with us on the
show thank you for having me and that's
your money briefing I'm J.R Whalen for
the Wall Street Journal
foreign
[Music]